>>> HEY THERE, FOLKING.
I'M RANDY KING OF KING BROTHERS
TOYOTA.
>> AND I'M SHORTY KING JR., AND
WE ARE OVERSTOCKED WITH TOYOTAS,
SIENNAS, COROLLAS, AND HIGH
LANDERS, ALL PART OF OUR KING
TOYOTA'S OVERSTOCK SALE-A-THON.
>> COME ON DOWN OFF HIGHWAY 8
EXIT 260 BECAUSE DEALS LIKE THIS
DON'T COME OFTEN.
>> GET YOUR BUTT DOWN HERE OFF
HIGHWAY 8, EXIT 260.
TAKE THE LEFT LANE.
>> YOU GOT TO GET HARD IN THAT
LEFT LANE BECAUSE IF YOU STAY
EVEN ONE SECOND IN THE RIGHT
LANE, YOU'LL GET STUCK IN THE
OVERFLOW LINE FOR THE NEW
RAISING CANES.
>> THE LINE BACKS UP TO THE
LIGHT ON TO THE OFF-RAMP AND
INTO THE HIGHWAY.
DO NOT STAY IN THE RIGHT LANE.
>> HARD, HARD LEFT, Y'ALL.
HARD TO THE LEFT WHEN YOU TAKE
260 OR YOU'LL MISS KING BROTHERS
TOYOTA'S OVERSTOCK SALE-A-THON.
>> WHY ARE WE OVERSTOCKED?
I'LL TELL YOU WHY, BECAUSE
NOBODY CAN GET HERE DUE TO THE
STUPID LONG CANE'S LINE TAKING
UP THE WHOLE DANG ROAD.
>> WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY SCREWED BY
THE BRENHAM CLAIM BER OF
COMMERCE AND DOWN COUNCILMAN
HUGO GALLEGOS.
>> HE HAS DEFILED 260.
>> THESE TRENDY CHAINS ALL COME
WITH THEIR OWN MASSIVE DRIVE
THROUGH LINES MANAGED ONLY BY A
HANDFUL OF iPADED TEENS.
>> WE ARE DEEP IN THE RED,
FOLKS, WHICH IS WHY CORPORATE
HAS SENT US THE NATION'S MOST
BEST AND JACKED SALESMAN, BRIAN
PAT MOORE.
>> THESE TWO ARE AFRAID TO GET
THEIR HANDS DIRTY.
CANES, YOU HAVE TWO HOURS TO GET
YOUR LINES OPEN.
I WILL REVEAL INGREDIENTS TO
YOUR SECRET SAUCE.
DON'T BELIEVE ME?
CHECK THIS OUT.
KETCHUP.
>> WE ARE DROWNING IN TACOMAS,
AND WE ARE TRAPPED HERE.
WE LITERALLY CANNOT LEAVE DUE TO
THE LONG AS HELL CANES LINES.
>> I HAVE MISSED SO MANY FAMILY
EVENTS THE THINGS LIKE NIECE'S
KRISTENING, FIRST DAUGHTER'S
RECITAL, AND EVEN LITTLE J.C. AS
NATHAN DETROIT.
>> I NOW SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE
COWARD HUGO GALLEGOS.
YOU HAVE DEFILED THE ONCE
BEAUTIFUL EXIT 260, AND IF THE
BIG ASS CANES LINE IS ALLOWED TO
STAND, KING BROTHERS TOYOTA WILL
FALL.
>> MY DAUGHTER HAILEY IS A
CLASSICS PROFESSOR AT BRENHAM
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, AND SHE HAS
DESCRIBED OUR PLIGHT AS A FUN
HOUSE MIRROR HELD UP AGAINST THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
I SAID, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT,
BABY GIRL.
ALL I KNOW IS I'M GETTING F'd IN
THE A BY HUGO GALLEGOS.
>> ALL THAT IS LOST BECAUSE WE
HAVE BRIAN PATMORE.
>> WELL, BRIAN PATMORE DON'T
PLAY NO GAMES.
NEXT INGREDIENT, PEPPER.
AND THE CLOCK BEGINNING ANEW.
TIKTOK, CANES, TIKTOK.
>> COME ON DOWN BECAUSE TIME IS
RUNNING OUT FOR KING BROTHER
TOYOTA'S SALE-A-THON.